the moment a missile slammed into an
apartment block in the south of the
ukrainian capital kiev
the attacks evidence say the ukrainian
authorities are russia's willingness to
hit civilian targets
we managed to escape we were in kitchen
we were lucky it was a direct hit in the
living room my wife and the elder child
have their legs broken our young child
was taken somewhere by rescuers
ukraine's president had warned of a
difficult night and for many it came
this the aftermath of fierce fighting
close to people's homes the ukrainian
army said it had destroyed a russian
military convoy trying to enter the city
vladimir zelinski affirmed kiev was
still in control of the capital and
surrounding cities
good morning ukrainians there has been a
lot of fake information online saying
that i'm calling on our army to lay down
arms and to evacuate
listen i am here we will not lay down
any weapons we will defend our state
because our weapon is our truth and the
truth is that this is our land our
country and our children and we will
defend all of that that's all i wanted
to tell you
in the village of bachmash in northern
ukraine russian forces were met by angry
civilians
one man trying to stop an advancing tank
with his bare hands
before being pulled to safety
and in the city of kharkiv a russian
missile landed in a children's
playground
russia meanwhile appears to be sending
even more troops and hardware across the
border into the country while insisting
it's not targeting ukrainian cities
during the night the russian military
used long-range high-precision weapons
sea and air launched cruise missiles to
strike the targets among the ukrainian
military infrastructure i'd like to
state once again strikes are only aimed
at ukrainian military targets
but that's not what the residents of
kiev are seeing or hearing people
continue to seek sanctuary underground
in basements the metro anywhere away
from the violence
according to western intelligence the
capitals not yet surrounded
those russian troops that have made it
as far as kiev are thought to be russian
special forces and saboteurs
but larger russian battle groups are
getting closer encountering stiff
ukrainian resistance as they approach
elsewhere the russians have made more
decisive games
this is the city of melitopol in the
country's south east where the russian
flag now flies over a local police
station
this video shot by russian state
television shows russian tanks on the
move in ukraine's east
this is europe's largest ground war
since world war ii vladimir putin and
some of these troops believe history's
on their side
we've been waiting since 2014. finally
i'll throw away this gun and will live
peacefully
amidst the fighting a light-hearted
exchange between a ukrainian driver and
some stranded russian soldiers lost and
out of
ukraine's one you guys have surrendered
says the driver can i tell you back to
russia
the truth is the conflict's far from
over ukrainian troops in the capital are
fortifying the city
soon in hours or days moscow will have
to make a decision
sit outside the capital and engineer
some political arrangement with the
ukrainian government or bring in troops
and heavy weaponry and do it in an even
more destructive way with the
possibility of mass civilian casualties
[Music]
the kremlin has the capacity for both
neve barker al jazeera